we begin with Russia President Vladimir
Putin has inaugurated a new natural gas
field in eastern Siberia that will allow
Russia to increase exports to China the
Kremlin hopes to augment gas sales as
its European trading partners divest
themselves from Russian energy
Moscow wants to boost gas sales to China
gas income is critical to the Kremlin to
bankroll Putin's war against Ukraine but
until now Russia has had very little
infrastructure to pump gas eastwards now
Putin has announced the development of
what he said would become the largest
gas field in eastern Siberia plus the
infrastructure to export the gas
the implementation of projects such as
the Kavita field the power of Siberia II
the Far Eastern route will make it
possible to increase gas supplies to the
east to 48 billion cubic meters by 2025
and 88 billion by 2030.
but that's still not even close to what
the West was buying from Russia before
the war
put in claims the new gas field in the
irkusk region has recoverable reserves
of 1.8 trillion cubic meters that would
make it around the 15th biggest in the
world the head of gas prom Alexei Miller
says that the kovita field is ready for
operation and would soon begin pumping
gas eastwards Russia is desperate to get
the project online as quickly as
possible to replenish dwindling walk
offers
but the projected timeline to build the
infrastructure shows that regardless of
the outcome of the war the Kremlin
expects Russia will be cut off from
Western markets for a long time to come
and staying with Russia fresh data is
out showing German exports to the
country have increased slightly to 1.2
billion euros in value in November it's
down over half on the same time last
year but still higher than when
sanctions began in March I spoke to
Alexander Libman professor of Russian
politics at the Free University of
Berlin he points out that there's still
plenty of trade not subject to sanctions
good example of pharmaceuticals
pharmaceutical experts are also down but
only by about 10 percent as opposed to
the pre-war state it was one of the
biggest export articles of Germany to
the Russian Federation
okay and um you know this uh we've seen
that um this is amount is around halved
since um the start of the uh the war the
invasion of Russia in Ukraine
um is this to be expected would you
expect this to continue to go down to to
stabilize where's this going to go
that's difficult to answer because it
massively depends upon what will going
to happen in Ukraine how the war is
going to develop and also how the
general state of the world economy and
of the German economy is going to
develop
so on the One Hand German companies did
have long-term interests in Russia but
on the other hand the Russian economy is
now also experiencing what looks like a
prologue to a long-term stagnation and
this could massively reduce their
interests to deal with Russia regardless
of the political situation so it's
difficult to tell okay I want to switch
to energy now so the EU agreed a gas
price cap earlier this week will this
significantly harm Russia in any way
what do you think
I don't think so I mean we have to be
realistic uh most measures which you
introduced is on the energy Market are
going to reduce Russia's capacity to
export to the EU they are already
reducing it now but actually what's
relevant for Russia is the budget
effects and budget effects given still
persistent opportunity of Russia to
export gas and oil to other countries
outside the Europe European Union
outside the United States which are not
part of the sanctions
um so as long as Russia has this
capacity it still has budget Revenue it
needs so I don't expect the harm to
Russia to be big enough to really change
the war developments well of course that
fits into what's happened today with
Russia's president opening a new gas
field with the goal of supplying China
how significant is this specifically for
Russia to what extent can it possibly
replace the European market for Russian
energy
I mean I don't expect China to replace
European markets for Russian energy this
is definitely not going to happen and I
also expect the prices Russia is going
to receive for its gas in China to be
lower and also the technology needed to
for example sustain the exports to China
it also depends on European Delivery so
things are not going to be easy for
Russia but on the other hand the really
relevant question for Putin's government
now is not whether you're going to
replace Europe what whether you're going
to get enough money to maintain the
government apparatus the War Machine and
the control over the country and this
most likely it's going to happen
okay so uh could be uh strategically
important even if Europe isn't uh
displaced there Alexander Libman thank
you very much for that
thank you